[Musik]
so hast du vielleicht so ein tampon
dabei danach fragen frauen in der
öffentlichkeit trainiert aber kaum
jemand traut sich öffentlich danach zu
fragen warum eigentlich
einblick in die kultur geschichte zeigt
schon früher und über jahrtausende
hinweg war die regelblutung mit charme
ekel und gar demütigung verbunden schon
aristoteles sah in der menstruation der
frau ein zeichen für ihre
minderwertigkeit er glaubte frauen seien
kälter als männer und deshalb nicht
imstande das blut sperma zu kochen eine
theorie die ziemlich lange einflussreich
war der historiker plinius der ältere
fürchtete gar um die ernte wegen der
menstruation giftig und unrein seiten
für die nonne und gelehrten hildegard
von bingen fing alles mit adam und eva
an sie sah in der periode eine folge des
sündenfalls typisch fürs mittelalter und
ruso meinte dass das übel der periode
daher komme dass frau sich schlicht
schlecht ernähren und zu wenig belege
überholte unsinn mag der mensch von
heute denken aber noch bis mitte des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts galt die
periode in der wissenschaft als gift
auch der umgang der weltreligionen mit
der periode zeigt werden instruiert ist
meist geniert hier einige beispiele
schon im ersten testament steht hat eine
frau blutfluss und ist solches blut an
ihrem körper soll sie sieben tage lang
in der unreinheit ihrer regel verbleiben
wer sie berührt ist unrein bis zum abend
auch im koran steht in der sure 2 vers
222 dass sich der mann von seiner frau
während der regel fernhalten sollte auch
in gewissen hinduistischen strömungen
sollen frauen sich während ihrer periode
von der familie abgrenzen und dürfen
gewisse tempel nicht betreten
fakt ist in der regel haftet der periode
nicht nur in religionen sondern auch
gesamtgesellschaftlich einstige an
aktueller beweis um kartons discrete zu
entsorgen haben zwei männer klinke
menstruation handschuhe entwickelt sie
wollten damit ein vermeintliches frauen
problem lösen
das land wollte das produkt wurde
eingestellt und auch sonst fordern
künstlerinnen und aktivistinnen schluss
mit das schon fertig mit der
unrealistischen blauen flüssigkeit und
her mit dem echten plus also in die
tonne mit dem kanton mit für uns
verbuchen
die menstruation ssten herzlich
willkommen
damit fängt man das blut der
menstruation auf das finden sie eklig
aber über 50 prozent der weltbevölkerung
sind frauen und die mehrheit davon
instruiert weiterhin aber herrschen
unwissen mythen und schweigen um sie so
ist die periode so scham behaftet und
was hat das ganze mit religion zu tun
das kläre ich mit der indologie und
philosophin angelika marina und mit der
kulturwissenschaftlerin elisabeth
lechner uns aus wien zugeschaltet
herzlich willkommen in beiden ja frau
lechner die weibliche monatsblutung ist
zwar alltäglich das thema ist in der
breiten bevölkerung aber irgendwie noch
nicht so ganz selbstverständlich also
einerseits es gibt es so was wie ein
menstruation stuck oder man spricht von
baden menstruation stubbs und dann
gleichzeitig aber habe ich in der
vorbereitung für diese sendung bemerkt
dass extrem viel darüber geschrieben
wird in den medien und speziell auch in
den sozialen medien das thema beackert
wird was würden sie denn sagen ist das
überhaupt noch legitim heute von einem
menstruation starboot zu sprechen
ich würde sagen das ist jedenfalls noch
legitim
im vergleich zu meiner teenagerzeit ich
bin jetzt 31
und wenn ich daran denke als ich das
erste mal meine periode bekommen habe
das war katastrophal wenn man da
irgendwo ein tempo gesehen hat eine
binde
da gab es große beschämung auch und die
sozialen praktiken waren sie ja das
musste man jedenfalls geheim halten und
ich würde sagen in den letzten 15 jahren
haben wir gerade durch die große
sichtbarkeit von sozialen medien auch
sichtbarkeit für dieses thema für dieses
tabuthema gewonnen
aber die frage ist welche art von
sichtbarkeit also ich glaube dass wir
einige symbolische
mächtige siege zu verzeichnen haben es
bekommen mittlerweile dokumentationen
über die periode einen oscar wir haben
ein motiv bekommen für das rote blut wir
sehen mittlerweile auch vermehrt rotes
blut in der werbung aber welche bilder
sind kommerzielle sie aber welche bilder
können wir gut sichtbar machen und das
sind genau die ambivalenzen dieses pop
feminismus der ja auf der ökonomien von
sichtbarkeit folgt der auf plattformen
basiert und passiert die mit unseren
daten milliarden milliarden gewinne
machen und dann gibt es natürlich sehr
gute grün der sich anzusehen warum
bestimmte bilder leichter
kommerzialisiert sind als andere
und ich denke dass wir über sehr poppige
bilder schon viel leichter sprechen
können ist ein erster schritt aber jetzt
geht es daran über perioden armut zu
sprechen über obdachlose menschen die
genauso menstruieren über diese
tiefgreifenden strukturellen probleme
die das thema auch betrifft gerade auch
zum beispiel medizinische versorgung da
greifen sie natürlich schon ganz viel
vor ich möchte das noch klären jetzt
auch mit ihnen frau marina wie sehen sie
das sind zwei generationen wie würden
sie das einschätzen wie auch das quasi
in ihrer zeit so war die die frau
lechner hat gerade mal gemeint die
letzten 15 jahre haben sehr viel
verändert also ich denke auch dass diese
neue sichtbarkeit die wir jetzt haben in
den letzten jahrzehnten einerseits eine
gute nachricht ist im sinne der
selbstbeschäftigung der frauen mit ihrem
eigenen körper und es ist von daher gut
dass jetzt neue bereiche der
öffentlichkeit erschlossen werden und
dass nicht mehr so wie das in meiner
jugend der fall war in den siebziger und
achtziger jahren dass es ein thema war
in frauengruppen wo man sich inspiziert
hat und überhaupt menstruation ein ganz
wichtiger punkt war um eben auch sich
von den ja herrschaftsformen die eben
auf körper frauenkörper bezogen sind
davon auch zu befreien das ging ja auch
um diese befreiung der frau nicht nur im
gesellschaftlichen sinne sondern auch
eben die freiheit dem eigenen körper
gegenüber
und auf der anderen seite
sehe ich aber auch dass gewisse von der
objektivierung von frauen also der blick
der fremdgesteuerten blick sozusagen auf
frauen weiter geht
jetzt würde ich sagen es gibt eine
transformation von tabuisierung die sich
auch auf hängt an neuen ideen über
perfektionierten körper keinen
leistungsfähigen körper und da haben wir
dann eine art von wiederum geburt meiner
menstruation verheimlichung ja ja und
ganz wichtig finde ich auch zu sehen
dass diese verschiedenen ebenen der
wahrnehmung bei uns nebeneinander stehen
die zum teil historisch aus
unterschiedlichen kontexten kommen aber
die tatsache dass auf der einen ebene
eine befreiung und neue sichtbarkeit da
ist heißt nicht dass auf der anderen
seite verheimlichung schweigen
überspielen
das weckt verformen sozusagen nicht
weiter zur tabuisierung strukturen
führen das ist hochinteressant weil man
kann jetzt gerade auch das beispiel
nehmen dass ich zu beginn auch in diesem
ein spieler gesagt habe also vor zirka
zwei monaten haben eben männer einen
handschuh erfunden der angeblich das
problem der menstruation lösen soll dass
sie die frau sollte nicht mehr mit einer
eigenen mit dem bloßen händen ihr blut
berühren müssen und kann dann noch
ungesehen den tampon entsorgen das hat
für extrem viel aufruhr gesorgt die
mussten dass das produkt auch einstellen
weil es so viel kritik erfahren hat und
das zeigt ja auch wie unglaublich
aufgeheizte dieser diskurs ist freilich
das zeigt es wirklich und es zeigt in
meiner in meinen augen schon auch wie
wirkmächtig diese online communitys
geworden sind also dass ich glaube
wirklich dass vor einigen jahrzehnten
noch es nicht möglich gewesen wäre sich
einem produkt so lautstark und auch so
kollektiv entgegenzustellen
gleichermaßen sind das die die aufreger
sozusagen die werden thematisiert aber
das darunter liegende bekommt die man
auch sehr viel weniger aufmerksamkeit
also ich gebe frau professor malen
ja absolut recht was mich daran
natürlich interessiert ist dieser ekel
wenn wir jetzt mal die zahlen nehmen
frauen menstruieren im durchschnitt
circa sieben jahre am stück 400 bis 500
mal und verlieren dabei insgesamt so
circa 30 liter blut das unterscheidet
sich natürlich auch man könnte sagen ist
es das natürlichste der welt
und trotzdem werden dann hygiene-artikel
mit dem versprechen vermarktet das
niemand etwas riecht dass niemand etwas
sieht das war so niemand etwas
mitbekommt von diesem natürlichen frau
marina was würden sie denn sagen weshalb
dieser ekel auch zustande kommt also ich
denke auch da gibt es wieder
verschiedene ebenen auf der einen seite
ist natürlich ekel auch etwas
natürliches ja es gehört sozusagen auch
zu den grund emotionen und grund
reaktionen auf beunruhigende vorgänger
also auch was gut ist ja natürlich also
es ist auch in vielen kulturen hat man
also gerade die körperausscheidungen
sind sozusagen etwas werden kommentiert
als substanzen wo ekel quasi das ist was
menschen im allgemeinen dann empfinden
und im falle jetzt der menstruation
gehört natürlich das menstruationsblut
zu diesem ganz großen bereich des
allgemeinen legitim ekels quasi vor
körperausscheidungen aber ich glaube am
punkt das menstruationsblut kommt noch
eine ambivalenz rein weil es eben eine
art von blutfluss ist der ungewöhnlich
ist gegenüber allen anderen situationen
wo blut aus dem körper austritt und
gerade das menstruationsblut verweist im
grunde auf ein innenleben des körpers ja
eines sonst durch im alltag natürlich
verdeckten körpers der sich daneben
zeigt in seiner ekelhaften sich selbst
von sich selbst abstoßen den schleimigen
aktivität die dann schließlich dazu
führt das ist natürlich in allen
menschlichen körpern überhaupt den
körpern der fall aber eben beim
frauenkörper zeigt sich eben dieses von
sich selbst ab
in diesem blutfluss und das spezielle
ist eben auch dass die art und weise wie
dieses blut abfließt
ja also wir haben also blut austritt zum
beispiel bei verwundung da kann das blut
spritzen und das ist auch etwas was
wiederum gut visualisiert bar ist im
sinne von schlachten und kriegsverletzte
sehr genau wird immer wieder gezeigt
aber gerade tropfen das langsam
fließendes blut sich langsam fortbewegen
das blut ist einfach ekel core notiert
weil es auf ansonsten unsichtbare
prozesse des körpers verweist und von
daher sozusagen einen einblick in den
sonst geschlossenen körper ermöglicht
der ansonsten nicht da ist und ich denke
auch in das kann man auch wenn man das
jetzt historisch betrachtet oder auch
sprachlich betrachtet gibt es ja
sprachen die diese beiden formen von
blut auch explizit unterscheiden und
diese unterscheidung spielt in der
westlichen tradition eine große rolle
also es gibt im latein diesen
unterschied zwischen dem inner dem blut
im inneren körper mango ist und dann
gibt es eben chor das aus dem dem körper
austretende blut was immer verbunden ist
mit dem verwundeten dem verletzten dem
kranken körper auch deinem körper dem
gewalt angetan wird und diese doppel
deutung spielt auch grad in im
christentum eine große rolle also mit
natürlich die kreuzigung jesus und diese
wunde die zugefügt wird
und da gibt es eben auch diesen
horrorcore es gibt es schon also in
den lateinischen quallen
mittelalterlichen quellen dieser
spezielle schrecken vor diesem
austretende blut auch als verbindung mit
tod verwundung sterblichkeit und so
weiter ich möchte dass mit dem ekel noch
ein bisschen weiter führen weil dieser
auch zu scham führen kann man spricht
immer wieder so wenn man von außen eben
das gefühl bekommen dass jetzt eben
diese dieses perioden blut wie sie das
auch ausgeführt haben
täglich seien dann resultiert es oft
auch in dieser perioden charme und meine
kollegin vanessa niekisch hat einen
dokumentarfilm zum thema gemacht
wenig es braucht also ja ich denke es
ist so wie mit
und ich glaube dass ich die gesellschaft
will
und genauso mit
[Gelächter]
droid alles anfang das ist heute auf
meine verwaltung im verwaltungsgebäude
vom kanton basel-stadt 370 leitet und
den post macht das wc gratis die gene
produkt entwickelt gab die un dass das
arbeiten sehr großer in folge das geld
nicht in der öffentlichkeit
ja das hat mich super möge damit wo
bundes es mich dass ich nicht erfolgter
sich nicht am start und ich mach das das
mini politische feinheiten abwartet dass
auch du blöd will ich nicht nur mit dem
geld angeschafft zuletzt freilich nur
sie haben ja zu scham und ekel jüngst
gerade gearbeitet auch ihre dissertation
geschrieben
wofür schämt man sich denn eigentlich
jetzt konkret ich finde extrem spannend
was wir gehört haben gerade in den doku
ausschnitts und auch von frau marina
weil wir dadurch sehen das scham und
ekel zutiefst geschlechtlich markiert
der emotionen sind also wie er mir sehr
geholfen der zugang von der britischen
kulturwissenschaftlerin sache arme zu
ekel die davon spricht dass das
eigentlich an performative akt ist sie
sagt wenn ich sage du bist eklig oder
noch schlimmer wow das ist eklig ich
dich also nur mehr zum objekt mache dann
bin ich das objekt das die macht hat zu
entscheiden wer hier objekt und subjekt
ist ich kann sagen du bist nur ein ekel
objekt setze dich damit herab
zusätzlich sagt sie auch und das bringt
so schön dieser sozialen machtstrukturen
ins spiel das ekel sticky ist also dass
er klebriges und potenziell alle anderen
die deg objekt zu nahe kommen anstecken
könnte und das sehen wir ganz gut auch
in den kommentaren auf sozialen medien
das heißt die einen sozusagen
solidarisieren sich mit
die objekte und sagen nein das sollte
doch gar nicht eklig sein das sind
patriarchale zuschreibungen und die
anderen sagen oder davon muss ich mich
distanzieren und über dieses wer hat das
recht zu sagen was eklig ist was zu viel
ist der der hat natürlich die dessen der
höheren machtposition und das haben wir
finde ich auch in der in der doku extrem
gut gesehen und genau genau dasselbe
gilt für scham
also sei niemand spricht in kretschmanns
von transformativen potenzial von scham
zuerst mal bedeutet charme ich möchte
mich unsichtbar machen ich möchte nicht
gesehen werden
ich möchte mich wirklich hier sofort aus
dieser rolle entfernen aber wenn ich es
schaffe dieses diese bestimmung von mir
zu streifen mich dann noch mit anderen
zu solidarisieren und gegen diese gegen
diese strukturen vorzugehen
dann können so sei niemand kollektive
emotionen sozialen wandel hervorrufen
und ich glaube einen gewissen beginn
oder eine fortsetzung von eigentlich
schon mindestens seit den 60-er 70-er
jahren bestehenden bewegungen sehen wir
da durchaus gerade was ich da
interessant finde oder es gibt diesen
unterschied zwischen zuschreibung und
dann auch selbst täglich sodass man das
selber aufnimmt und ich möchte da auch
noch weil sie jetzt gerade gesagt haben
in den sozialen medien mit dem ganzen
kommentaren es gab eben genau auf diesen
film auch sehr viele kommentare ich habe
einige mitgenommen einige frauen oder
einige personen überhaupt seien sehr
dankbar dass man endlich über das thema
auch spricht und andere fanden das dann
eigentlich nur unnötig und eben eklig
wie wir gerade besprochen haben dass man
menstruationsblut im fernsehen zeigt sie
haben zum beispiel gefragt ob denn alles
was natürlich sei auch unbedingt gezeigt
werden müsse und ob es nicht irgendwo
auch ein vereinfacht auch eine intim und
privatsphäre gebe
was ist da ihre haltung war li na ja
also ich denke auf der einen seite muss
man ganz klar sagen und frau lechner hat
es ja gerade auch noch mal betont also
diese ganze zuschreibung kampf geht es
natürlich auch immer um macht und wer
hat eigentlich die deutungsmacht für das
was sich abspielt und auf der anderen
seite ist es aber auch so dass dieser
dieser ganze diskurs über scham und das
eklige im moment sicher auch abspielt in
einem gesamtgesellschaftlichen
zusammenhang von dem auch männer ja
betroffen sind nämlich dass eben ein
körper der nicht kontrolliert ist die
ganze zeit also das ist auch diese
verbindung zwischen schaukel und diesen
fragen der kontrolle
das eben wir in einen gesellschaftlichen
diskurs auch in einem medien diskurs und
jetzt nicht nur die sozialen medien
sondern eben umfassen davon sind uns
aufhalten wo jeder art von dysfunktional
i tät von einschränkung von
leistungsfähigkeit kontrollverlust und
so weiter ist etwas was peinlich ist ja
was scham auslöst und das ist
gleichzeitig etwas was eben dadurch das
begleitende institutionen fehlen dem der
einzelnen personen als verantwortung
zugeschrieben wird also das heißt man
muss sich selbst darum kümmern
schafft man dass das irgendwie die
schmerzen auszuhalten hat man sozusagen
das ganze equipment mit tampons binden
unsere hat man wechselt leitungen und
was weiß ich
und wenn man das nicht leistet ist man
peinlich man muss sich schämen man hat
einfach nicht den standards den
allgemeinen standards eines immer
leistungsfähig wirkenden immer irgendwie
perfekt daherkommenden körpers erfüllt
und das glaube ich ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt auch warum das für die
frauen nach wie vor an ein riesen thema
ist gerade weil man ja auch viel mehr in
der moderne mehr öffentlichkeit einfach
hat durch teilnahme am berufsleben was
ja auch wirklich ein großer unterschied
ist zu anderen zeiten
sie sprechen genau die moderne an machen
wir doch mal einen sprung zurück in der
antike galt die menstruation als
reinigungsprozess der frauen zu viele
nährstoffe in ihrem körper hätten die
ausgeschieden werden müssten und
aristoteles und die progress werteten
die regelblutung als etwas unreines ab
bis ins 20 jahrhundert wurde periode gar
nachgesagt sie seien giftig und würde
zum verderben von lebensmitteln
beitragen da frage ich mich jetzt eben
genau ist denn die menschen ihren de
frau eine jahrhundertealte schreckens
gestellt
ja also sie ist einerseits eine
schreckens gestalt und das ist auf der
einen seite sicherlich sehr sehr gut
festzumachen an tatsächlich dem
philosophen aristoteles der ja ein sehr
prägendes modell über die dem weiblichen
körper im unterschied zum männlichen
körper entworfen hat eben dass dadurch
im grunde die frau eigentlich als
materie definiert wird die eigentlich
das material liefert um dann beliebt zu
werden eine materie die dann belebt wird
die geformt wird vergeistigt wird durch
den männlichen samen und die menschen
menstruieren der frau und das was dann
das menstruationsblut ist mit ganzen mit
den ganzen substanzen die dabei
rauskommen ist quasi frau pur wenn man
das mal so zugespitzt sagen möchte das
heißt frau einfach als etwas was
unproduktiv ist nicht befruchtet nicht
fruchtbar nicht sozusagen hat kein leben
empfangen und ist von daher eben das was
ich von sich selbst ab stößt wenn es
nicht quasi belebt wird durch eine ja
eine männliche kraft die dann quasi die
materie der frau formt und das hat
sozusagen zu einer einordnung von
menstruation und frauenkörper als eben
passiv was natürlich große nachwirkungen
hat für die ganze bedeutung von
sexualität die frau als passives wesen
die eigentlich von sich aus gar keine
sexuellen bedürfnisse hat und so weiter
gibt es dann lange diskurs aber eben auf
der anderen seite gibt es dann sozusagen
diese schiene wo man sagt ja die
fruchtbarkeit und ganz wichtig und die
frauen haben da einen riesigen potenzial
und eine kraft und seine positive um
wendung ins genau dieser positiven
wendung und es zeigt gerade die
vitalität des weiblichen körpers in
einer vorbildhaften weise dass der
frauenkörper halt eben in der lage ist
diese selbst reinigungs und
selbstheilungsprozesse immer wieder
regelmäßig durchzuführen und da haben
wir auch hildegard von bingen war ja
genannt
da gibt es ja durchaus auch traditionen
wo das menstruationsblut verwendet wird
für medizinische rezepturen oder in der
alchemie und
diese diese feiern feiern die dimension
ist eben auch ganz wichtig ich möchte
das wort aber noch ganz kurz an frau
lechner übergeben jetzt mit diesem
gerade das was wir gerade gehört haben
historisch und diese schreckens gestellt
würden sie sagen das können sie noch auf
heute anwenden oder inwiefern kann man
das noch auf heute anwenden
ja also ich glaube man kann das sehr gut
man kann einen guten blick zurück und
dann einen einen einen schönen bogen in
die gegenwart spannen wenn wir zum
beispiel in die 60er 70er jahre schauen
die zweite welle des feminismus da gab
es ja ganz tolle radikale künstlerinnen
die sich genau mit diesen zuschreibungen
auseinandergesetzt haben carolis nehmen
zum beispiel hat gesagt ihr wollt uns
über unsere reproduktiven fähigkeiten
und organe abwerten ja dann mache ich
genau das zum thema stellt sich nackt
auf die bühne und zieht ein
beschriebenes schriftstück aus ihrer
wohl wahr
ihr wird quasi der öffentliche raum
verwehrt ihr wird gesagt du bist eben
körper du bist kein geist und sie stellt
sich hin und sagte nein nein das geht
alles zusammen sozusagen in das fand ich
schon
das waren die radikalen eigentlich die
diese vorkämpferinnen und wir sehen das
wirklich noch heutzutage also wir diese
politiken von pia marie to much
information heißt sie immer ganz schnell
in den digitalen medien
das ist jetzt aber zu viel das
grausliche wer bestimmt das denn und
dann sieht so menschen wie li na dann
mit ihrer fernsehserie girls oder zum
beispiel auch charlotte roche
feuchtgebiete im deutschsprachigen raum
aber vielleicht ist ja auch eine macht
welche geschichten die uns erzählen aber
vielleicht ist es ja auch einfach zu
viele informationen also ich möchte dass
doch noch einmal hervorheben
viele leute empfinden das also was
privates also was sagt uns eigentlich
das ist dass es dieses klabuhn nicht
auch geben kann ich eben ich sags ganz
ehrlich ich möchte es auch nicht
unbedingt öffentlich über meine
menstruation sprechen
das finde ich extrem spannend weil auch
schon seit den sechziger siebziger vier
anfragen gehe ja das private ist
politisch oder und ich glaube dass das
private so lange politisch ist und
solange dieses tabu besprochen und
gezeigt werden muss und so lange müssen
wir dafür kämpfen solange einfach auch
zum beispiel medizinische
gleichberechtigung besteht also es ist
ja wirklich so dass im bereich
endometriose erkrankungen rund um die
menstruation einfach dadurch
wir nicht darüber sprechen gibt es kein
bewusstsein dafür und wenn dann auch in
der forschung ein diese unausgesprochene
fitte junge weiße männliche enorm
herrscht dann find solche probleme
komplett unter den tisch und das darf
einfach nicht passieren weil es ja so
viele menschen betrifft das ist ja
wirklich keine rand diagnose sozusagen
und ich glaube dieses tabu ist insofern
muss so lange besprochen werden so lange
müssen wir leider ein auf die nerven
gehen dies nicht hören wollen weil es
hier wirklich einfach um lebenswege geht
und wirklich um ja tief greifender
tiefgreifende einschnitte
gut dann möchte ich aber besser
verstehen woher kommt das denn dieses
tabu kann sie uns das ein bisschen
einordnen weil es zieht sich offenbar
durch verschiedene religionen und durch
verschiedene kulturen also dass das tabu
jetzt der thema die sie also der
thematisierung von menstruation also
wenn man das wiederum
kulturgeschichtlich betrachtet muss man
eben auch sagen allein schon das wort
tabu wäre ganz gut wenn man quasi den
original bedeutung sind sich daran
erinnert dass es eben auch wieder beides
ist also etwas was verboten ist aber
warum warum ist es verboten weil das
besonders kraftvoll weil es etwas
sakrales ist was abgegrenzt wird vom
alltag und die tabuisierung dass diese
form der tabuisierung von menstruation
und diese eingrenzung und macht das
kurse zur frauenkörpern da wird ja immer
wieder gesagt na gut das ist die
männliche herrschaft aber gerade wenn
wir die religion dazu nehmen
finde ich eigentlich diese perspektive
wenn man es nur auf machtstrukturen
politische machtstrukturen fokussiert
ist es zu eng gefasst aber sie sagen die
papiere jetzt in bezug auf diese
ausgrenzung die die greift zu kurz
also sie greift zu kurz für eine
patriarchat nur versteht im sinne der
herrschaftsstrukturen der politischen
herrschaft strukturen die man ändern
muss also dieses frauen an die macht und
dann recht richtet sich alles andere
quasi von selbst
und wir sehen halt der erfahrung der
moderne ist wir sehen halt das
funktioniert nicht sonst würden wir ja
heute nicht zusammensetzen
jedenfalls nicht an all den bereichen
die man erwarten könnte dass das dass es
da stattgefunden hat
und ich bin finde da immer ganz nützlich
aus nano logisch soziologischen
perspektive das zu verbinden mit dem
wort der kosmologie weil man dann auch
sehr gut den verbindung hat zur religion
und per piâbo der französische soziologe
spricht in bezug auf die analyse von
männlicher herrschaft von andre
zentrischen technologien auf ihren mann
konzentrierten kosmologen und das schöne
an dem costello kosmologie begriff ist
eben dass sich die perspektive auf das
was tabu ist und nicht tabu ist immer
wechselt nachdem wo man sich gerade
verbinde befindet das heißt es gibt da
eben unterschiedliche bewertungs
mechanismen aber trotzdem was diesen
andere zentrischen kosmologie die auch
eben von den religionen zum teil aus
buchstabiert wird eben gemein ist ist
das einerseits die frau als
unverzichtbarer bestandteil natürlich
ihren platz braucht auch ihre verehrung
und achtung braucht aber auf der anderen
seite eben eingelegt werden muss
eingegrenzt werden muss und gerade was
die ihre produktions funktionen und eben
sexualität und diese für jede
gesellschaftsordnung prekären öffnungen
und schließung und veränderung der
gesellschaft und überhaupt von ordnung
beinhaltet lassen sie uns das noch etwas
weiter spinnen weil ich habe ja zu
beginn auch gesagt dass es im erstmals
im alten testament diesen passus gibt
der quasi die berührung der menstruieren
frau verbietet es wird oft als unreine
phase verstanden
die menstruation ich frage mich weshalb
genau und vor allen dingen auch von was
für einer unreinheit sprechen wir hier
eigentlich
also ich denke das ist vielleicht ganz
hilfreich wenn man wenn man jetzt gerade
auch die religion mit rey nimmt dass man
da auch verschiedene sozusagen form von
religion struktur form von religionen
unterscheidet
und gerade die zitate also die wir
gehört haben aus dem ersten testament
und aus dem koran sind eigentlich
typisch wir haben auch ähnliches im
hinduismus typisch für religionen die
quasi an
ihren anhängern sie durch das leben zu
begleiten und zwar vor allen dingen mit
ritualen mit lebenszyklus ritualen aber
auch mit alltags begleitenden ritualen
und in dem moment wo wir eine starke
ritual dimension hat haben
er ist immer die frage wer führt diese
rituale durch und vor allen dingen ist
die kontinuität der rituale gesichert um
dann sozusagen die gesamt ordnung des
lebens mit abzusichern
und es ist eigentlich in allen diesen
religionen der fokus immer auf die
entscheidenden wendepunkte im leben
nicht nur des einzelnen sondern auch das
der familie einer gesellschaft insgesamt
und das ist eben geburt tot und
menstruation und man muss aus dieser
perspektive betrachtet die menstruation
als konnten in einem kontinuum sehen mit
den unrein heiz und reinheit regeln für
die gelten auch in die in diesen
religiösen diskursen für geburt tot
und das heißt es sind jeweils temporäre
phasen der unreinheit die einfach
deutlich machen es ist jetzt mal eine
aus alltägliche situation das heißt man
ist auch entbunden von rituellen
pflichten oder man hat dann hat ein
verbot rituell rituale durchzuführen
aber man ist auch zum teil eben
entbunden von den anforderungen und
pflichten des alltags also diese
vorstellung man hat wenn man ist
andauernd kann man immer dasselbe zu
jeder zeit machen
zeit ist nur noch linear sie ist nicht
mensur irrt mansory administration
sie hat keine qualitative dimension das
ist eben in diesen rituell begleitenden
religionen ganz stark dieser fokus auf
diese qualitativen umschlags punkte
und von daher muss man unreinheit in
diesem sinne nicht als etwas
prinzipielles sehen und auch die frau
gilt nicht als unrein ja auch im
hinduismus nicht sondern es ist auch
wenn sie sozusagen die frau durch lebt
ja am meisten dieser dieser anwendungs
punkt ja aber es sind die tempo es sind
eben temporär deshalb muss sie eben man
könnte auch sagen deshalb muss das auch
besonders
geschützt werden weil es so prekär ist
also wir haben ja zum beispiel auch
diese unreinheit nach der geburt ich
meine sie gerne realisieren kann wären
auch wir nennen das wochenbett ja und
ist es immer noch so dass man sagt gut
der soll das rum da sollen das
reduzieren bloß nicht mehr so lang sie
muss wieder arbeiten also diese
funktionalität ist bei uns sehr sehr
stark und in den religion ist ganz ganz
wichtig dass diese unreinheit gebote
nicht prinzipiell diskriminierend sind
das finde ich jetzt hochinteressant auch
wenn wir das auf heute spiegeln frau
lechner ich habe das gefühl man kann da
schon heute von einer utopie auch des
reinen körpers sprechen immer wieder
wenn es um rasur geht und wie reagiert
wird auf zum beispiel nicht rasierte
frauenbeine eben dass man menstruation
nicht sehen darf und so weiter es gibt
so was wie ein ideal des reinen körpers
der sich eben frei macht auch von diesen
ganzen ausscheidungen sehen sie die da
eine ähnlichkeit auf jeden fall das so
wir können
ich kann das der forschung berichten
dass es eine zunahme des schönheits
drucks gibt das heißt eine immer immer
strengere anforderungen an die an die
optik die man haben soll und die bezieht
sich mittlerweile auch auf das
innenleben das heißt was gefragt ist es
ganz genau wie frau marina sagt dieses
authentischer dieses feature dieses
einsatzbereite aber jede form von
schwäche jede form von schmerz jede form
von nicht funktionieren ist gar nicht so
gerne gesehen
und das bedeutet halt auch ich finde
hier in diesem kontext inbegriff der
schönheits arbeit so passend weil man
dann wirklich sieht wieviel zeit
ressourcen und ganz oft auch schmerzen
in dieses aussehen fließen das wir
brauchen um überhaupt am arbeitsmarkt
oder in sozialen beziehungen als
einsatzbereit zu gelten sozusagen also
wirklich all die haarentfernung die
gesichtspflege schminken die haarpflege
das rasieren all diese tätigkeiten wie
lange das dauert und was das kostet
zeigt schon auf das ist ein großes
ungleichgewicht gerade in einem binär
geschlechtlichen kontext zwischen
männern und frauen ist bei männern ist
es so wenn die sich gewaschen haben
sozusagen und dann gegen eine gepflegte
frisur haben dann sind sie schon fertig
bei frauen folgt noch so so viel mehr
um überhaupt als gepflegt lesbar zu sein
er selbst habe ich sehr viel rein in
diese menstruation dynamiken dass da
frage ich mich halt schon weshalb denn
genau dieses konzept der reinheit in
religion an ein so cent eine so zentrale
komponente spielt also das hängt das
hängt natürlich einmal an diesem was ja
mary dackel ist sehr schön
ja die die ethnologin soziologin man
wirklich so schön beschreibt als die
störung der ordnung durch alles was als
unrein dekliniert wird oder definiert
wird
also dieses berühmte matter of place wie
sie das ist ja sagt reinheit ist quasi
ordnung und das was als schmutz taxiert
wird ist quasi die störung dieser genau
und das wird eben sehr deutlich auch in
bezug auf diese körper definition kann
man das sehr schön illustrieren dass
wenn man sich fragt wann es eine ordnung
eine ordnung wenn sie sozusagen
eingegrenzt ist und wenn es eine
geschlossene ordnung ist und vor allen
dingen diese durchlässigen prozesse der
osmose man muss was reinlassen machen es
dass rauslassen müssen sind nur dann
akzeptabel und stören die ordnung nicht
wenn sozusagen eine kontrolle ist im
sinne der reinigungsmaßnahmen und das
ist die eine ebene und das wird zum
beispiel ich hab's ja gesagt in den
religionen die eben das rituell
begleiten
im grunde sind das sozusagen regeln und
formen um genau diese porosität von
körpern und damit auch von ordnungen zu
regeln und rituell zu begleiten
es wird dann in dem moment ein anderer
reinheit diskurs aufgeschlagen wenn in
religion und gesellschaften die frage
ist warum warum ist das eigentlich so
wieso sind die körper so wie sie sind ja
warum haben wir diese schleimigen
blutigen verletzbaren körper warum ist
der körper so fragil und da haben wir
dann verschiedene moralisch unterlegte
straff negative also natürlich die
vertreibung aus dem paradies da ist ja
auch die vorstellung wäre eva im
paradies geblieben dann würde hätte sie
nie menstruieren müssen und würde auch
nicht menstruieren sondern es ist dann
eigentlich vom die solchen straftat
einfach diese frage ja wieso also im
grunde geht es darum warum ist die
körperliche existenz so fragil und wie
kommen wir eigentlich wieder in einen
laib der nicht so fragil nicht so nicht
sowohl der abel und schmerz behaftet ist
und das ist ja genau das angebot von
religion und diese einheits diskurse die
dann auch tatsächlich frauen
diskriminieren und eine frauenverachtung
haben und das kann neben diesen
rituellen begleitungen durchaus stehen
wie zum beispiel ja auch im christentum
das ist dass man dann sagt ja die frauen
haben halt bei denen zeigt sich eben
diese dieser verfallen haid des körpers
ganz besonders und von daher ist wird
dann eben diese reinheit des kurs an der
unreinheit der frau und damit auch einer
moralischen fragwürdigkeit von frauen
fest gemacht genau so machen wir es doch
mal konkret ich frage mich natürlich
weshalb denn konkret dieses
menstruationsblut eine störung dieser
ordnung bedeutet ich möchte da auch noch
hervorheben es gibt ja normieren der
beschränkungen für frauen ganz konkret
wenn es wenn sie menstruieren also dass
sie nicht in temple gehen kann dass sie
nicht beten sollten dass sie auch nicht
in moscheen gehen sollten ja ja aber das
hat das hat wiederum zu tun mit dem mit
diesem tabu also dieses diese andere
seite des tableaus ist eben der schutz
des außer alltäglich heiligen also das
quasi dabei eine beschränkung ist nicht
in schutz
doch es wird sozusagen die die der
kontakt mit einem sozusagen porösen des
funktionalen körper der eben mit mit
ausscheidungen beschäftigt ist
da wird eben abgegrenzt er der kontakt
zu dem sozusagen außer alltäglichen
sakralen ritualen religiösen raum der
genau im grunde die transzendieren von
diesen ganzen beschweren dessen der
körperlichkeit verspricht und
symbolisiert und von da her und es geht
natürlich auch daran dass ist ja auch in
vielen religionen die begründung
so zum beispiel im hinduismus warum
können frauen nicht andere religiöse
ämter durchführen weil sie eben aufgrund
ihrer menstruation nicht die kontinuität
der ritual handlung und der religiösen
begleitung garantieren können und
deshalb ist dann eine menopause zum
beispiel eröffnet die chancen dann
solche ämter wie möglich aufzunehmen
oder andere formen des religiösen lebens
aufzunehmen ist etwas was wir in
religion dann auch haben
was würden sie denn sagen frau lechner
in ihrer forschung haben sie ein ponton
jetzt auch bei den männern dazu gefunden
jetzt ja auch diese störung der ordnung
die wir gerade so ein bisschen auch
ausgelegt haben
ich würde gerne noch kurz davor
hinzufügen zu dem was frau marina gesagt
hat dass es natürlich konsequenzen für
das leben von menschen hat wenn sie ein
scham behaftet das leben können wenn sie
lernen dass diese prozesse eklig sind
dreckig sind das wenn man das
phänomenologische betrachtet schränkt
das ja ihre möglichkeit ein auf die welt
zu wirken
man traut sich nicht raum einzunehmen
man weiß man muss das unsichtbar machen
und bettina stangneth die philosophin
spricht in ihrem neuen buch sechs kultur
vom körper kompetenz also eigentlich wie
soll man in einem so von international
verflochtenen diskriminierungs
strukturen geprägten umfeld einen freien
zugang zur eigenen körperlichkeit finden
wenn das alles schon so stark belasteten
so stark mit bedeutungen zuschreibungen
belegt ist und ein ponton zu männern
also wir finden jedenfalls dass auch der
druck schön auszusehen und der druck
einen gewissen ideal zu genügen
auch für männer steigt und das ist
natürlich besonders problematisch wenn
wir von so toxischen formen von
männlichkeit ausgehen die härte und
größe und stärke aus machen und dann
dazu führen dass männer die aufgrund
ihrer körper beschämt werden noch nicht
einmal darüber reden können bei dieser
verletzlichkeit von der frau marina auch
gesprochen haben wiederum beschämt wird
als etwas ab zu wertendes jetzt sind wir
schon schon ganz im fokus auch das des
körpers und der körperlichkeit
entzerrten das zuvor auch so schon
aufgenommen
das nämlich körperfunktion jetzt ganz
konkret der weibliche körper hat also
die er durchläuft sei es von der
menstruation sei es die geburt
daneben menopause haben sie auch erwähnt
wo dann das ganze so sich ein bisschen
um wendet da ist der weibliche körper
eben in religionen viel stärker
reglementiert heißt das auch im
umkehrschluss dass man in religionen den
weiblichen körper als unreiner versteht
oder ist das nicht der korrekte schluss
also wiederum muss man da unterscheiden
was für eine art von religion also
religion ist ja nicht gleich religion
also wir noch mal diese rituelle man
kann das reglementierung nennen ist von
den religiösen traditionen aus der
innenperspektive ist es auch eine
anerkennung der unverzichtbarkeit von
frauen ja für die gesamte für das
gesamte funktionären der welt und auch
der familie und gerade dieser fokus auf
geburt und menstruation und diese
dysfunktional i tät das heißt diese sich
regierung oder dass man sagt gut ist
jetzt unrein das heißt keine keine
hausarbeit keine keine pflichten gar
nichts das ist ja auch irgendwie ein
zeichen des schutzes gerade in
religiösen kontexten oder auch
historischen epochen wo eben gerade
geburt und alles unkontrollierte
blutfluss und so weiter als hoch
bedrohlich und lebensgefährlich das muss
man eben auch sehen gegolten hat und
deshalb auch die versorgung von frauen
vor der geburt also dass man alle
wünsche erfüllen soll diese diese
reglemente gibt es ja auch es ist
sozusagen die andere seite in den
regionen
es wird immer dann quasi der
frauenkörper als das schreckensbild auch
gerade dieses innenlebens des
frauenkörpers angesehen wenn religion
entweder sich total fokussieren auf eine
befreiung überhaupt vom körper die quasi
den körper selbst als den die die grund
übel aller beschwernisse an sich fesseln
genau als fessel und gerade deshalb
warum weil eben der körper nie rein ist
das heißt man kommt nie in einen
stabilen zustand eines geschlossenen
geordneten nicht mehr an tastbaren nicht
mehr wohl raten genau aufs land
geschlechts übergreifen
ja aber es wird vor allen dingen am
männerkörper fest gemacht weil die es
diese vorstellung also das ist ja auch
in vielen asketischen religionen so ob
das jetzt buddhismus ist oder auch teile
im christentum haben wir das auch oder
oder im hinduismus im yoga dass man
diese vorstellung hat eigentlich die die
wirkliche askese in ihrer form können
eigentlich nur die männer machen weil
sie bis zu ihrem letzten atemzug mit
sexualität konfrontiert sind und also
aufgrund eben leider ein bloßes genau
wie können immer noch sozusagen
sexualität hat für männer folgen und das
ist bei den frauen eben nicht so was die
asketischen wenn sie so als kritische
texte lesen die ärgern und sich dann
auch darüber dass das sozusagen bei den
frauen anders ist
aber da ist eigentlich diese also wenn
man sagt sexualität und reproduktion ist
quasi das was eigentlich die
leidensgeschichte des körpers ausmacht
weil das im grunde durch die schmerzen
ursache schlechthin ist usw wird das
natürlich am weiblichen körper fest
gemacht weil es da alles passiert
letztlich und von daher steht der
weibliche körper einerseits für die
attraktivität von sexualität und diesen
attraktivität von familienleben und
fortleben durch nachkommen aber in den
asketischen religionen wird gesagt das
ist genau die verfallen haid über die
man wegkommen das so wird man nie
unsterblich perfekt und rein diesen
diamanten im körper ja oder den
transferierten körper im christentum das
ist eigentlich das was anzustreben ist
nur so wird man rein wenn man sozusagen
diese art von körperlichkeit anstrebt
und das passiert eben darauf dass man
keinen kontakt mit frauen hat ja sowieso
nicht also zölibat oder eben
enthaltsamkeit regeln bei münchen usw
kontakt zu männern ja das ist ja
sozusagen diese diese homosexuelle ebene
wird eher ausgeblendet
ja es ist natürlich das gilt natürlich
das verbot von sexualität in allen
formen per se aber natürlich
besonders prekär und da kommen wir
wieder zurück zu mary der class
irgendwie die ordnung
es wird dann wirklich bedrohlich wenn
die ordnung gestört wird das heißt es
gibt dann kinder ein mensch wird auf
einmal vater und diese
gesellschaftlichen ansprüche das dann
hat also das ist alles etwas wo dann
tatsächlich der frauenkörper tabu ist
naja und dann kommt natürlich noch dazu
ein großes problem im asketischen
religion ist immer einfach die sexuelle
erregbarkeit die auch eben nicht
nachlässt im kloster und deshalb ist der
frauenkörper an sich eine attraktion
punkt den man vermeiden muss und da gibt
es zum beispiel im buddhismus diese
berühmt berüchtigten meditation über den
frauenkörper wo ein mönch eben ein mönch
da gibt es das neue stufen der
sogenannten leichen betrachtung und es
fängt dann irgendwie an also an dem an
der gerade frisch verstorbenen leiche
und dann macht man sich klar ja die
frauen thema schönheit sie sehen so
schön aus und aber wenn man richtig
hinguckt ist es im grunde ein
ein körper der schleimt und blutet und
einfach ganz entsetzlich ist und das
muss man sich vergegenwärtigen immer
dann wenn man sich angezogen fühlt von
der schönheit einer frau soll man sich
vergegenwärtigen sollte man quasi sowie
dem röntgenblick durch die haut durch
gucken und dann sehen was da eigentlich
wirklich stattfindet und wie hast du
hier kann haftkraft ja und ja also man
möchte also wer wer sich das klar macht
der versteht kein mann warum ist dass er
sich mit einer frau abgibt frau lechner
sie sie nicken und lachen
ich finde es extrem spannend das ist so
der wahnsinnig gute überleitung zu dem
was ich sagen wollte weil lori penny zum
beispiel zitiert in die fleisch und
macht einen unterschied zwischen
erotischem kapital und dieser echten
intimität dieser echten sexualität sie
sagt ja weibliche körper und ihre
sexualität die dürfen gerne im
öffentlichen raum stattfinden solange
man mit ihnen oder am besten
fragmentierten körperteilen einem 67
einem schönen dekolleté einem runden
hintern produkte und dienstleistungen
verkaufen kann
sobald aber diese frau selbstbestimmt
ihre 6
die täter nehmen möchte und sagt ich bin
mehr als mein körper und es geht mir um
das fühlen es geht mir um die
zwischenmenschliche erfahrung und nicht
um das format vermarkten von produkten
nicht und meine optik dann haben wir es
ganz schnell mit einer mit gegenwind zu
tun und laurie penny macht genau wie
frauen molina jetzt gesagt hat macht an
diesen körperflüssigkeiten an dem
vermeintlich ewigen eigentlich dass
freiheit moment fest sozusagen das ist
doch nun wirklich nicht kommerzialisiert
war dieses dieser letzte intimität
dieses einfach zwischenmenschliche wo es
egal ist wie man aussieht wo man sich
auf das fühlen und spüren konzentriert
und das bei sich sein aber das ist eben
ganz schwierig in einer gesellschaft in
die zutiefst logistisch geprägt ist also
menschen aufgrund des äußeren bewertet
aufwertet die schönen und abwehrte jene
die es hässlich oder gar gelten und in
einer gesellschaft die zeitgenossen muss
man sagen von patrick hart und
kapitalismus bestimmtes und da hat eine
riesige industrie ein großes interesse
daran immer neue marken zu kreieren um
immer neue produkte zu verkaufen wenn
wir daran denken was gerade an vulva
liebten für korrekturen vorgenommen
werden und was nicht alles noch
beschämender ist damit man noch immer
mehr neue produkte verkaufen kann
wird einem jahr ganz schwindlig also
dieses zurück zum körper zum fühlen
stadt sehen wird einem extrem schwer
gemacht in einer zutiefst verschachtelt
diskriminierenden welt das finde ich
faszinierend weil sie neben da auch
wieder auf was sie eigentlich zu beginn
gesagt haben dass ein tabu auch
kapitalisiert wird und dass da zum
beispiel eben genau so was wie das
menstruation stubbs eigentlich ganz
gelegen kommt genau für diese
kapitalisierung das klingt ja so als
wäre eine eine treibende kraft dahinter
was sehen sie denn da wenn sie sagen
quasi dem markt ist interessiert daran
dass das dass das leute beschämt und
ekel empfinden usw
was was ist das genau was ist die
treibende kraft wirklich dahinter ich
glaube dass es extrem schwierig zu
bewerten weil alle alle diese formen von
aktivismus von aufmerksam machen
zum passieren ja auch in diesen systemen
das heißt ich glaube es gibt dieses
freie außerhalb das so ganz radikales
und einer mainstream sichtbarkeit
bekommt das gibt es einfach nicht also
man bewegt sich so quasi auf plattformen
die schon bedingen dass man mit diesen
logischen mitspielt
und da hat zum beispiel auch der
feminismus noch ganz viel reflexion
arbeit zu tun weil auch feministinnen
schon die suffragetten anfang des
zwanzigsten jahrhunderts wussten dass
sie um als progressiv und eis als
entwickelt da war diese fürchterliche
entwicklungs diskurse um als würdig für
das wahlrecht zu gelten
die haben immer die schönsten also
jüngsten und norm schönsten weißen
frauen vorgeschickt um zu zeigen wir
sind zivilisiert dasselbe in der zweiten
welle also bloggers deinem war so schön
dass sie sozusagen beim feind undercover
gehen konnte die wahl playboy er war
blake beim playboy undercover unterwegs
und da hat auch niemand reflektiert ja
warum hat die sophie sichtbarkeit
bekommen diese wunderschöne frau was war
mit den ganzen schwarzen frauen die
vielleicht diesen logischen gerade auch
wegen kolonialer schönheitsideale nicht
genügen und die nicht dieser
öffentlichkeit bekommen also
sichtbarkeit ist glaube ich ein sehr
zweischneidiges schwert und schwer
schwer ist damit umzugehen
ich möchte jetzt noch gegen schluss hin
auch noch einigen einen globalen blick
wagen 2009/10 sie haben das ganz zu
beginn auch gesagt gewann der kurzfilm
the tent of sendens einen oscar für den
besten dokumentarfilm
und er dreht sich um die unwissenheit
und eben auch das tabu rund um die
menstruation in indien
[Musik]
feiern not anbringen
unter
[Musik]
wer in manchen teilen der welt bedeutet
dass es einsetzen der menstruation auch
das ende der schulzeit weil schlicht die
die die produkte zum auffangen des
blutes fehlen
man spricht auch immer wieder von
perioden armut wie zeigt sich das denn
konkret frau marina ja also gerade in
indien das war jetzt das beispiel ist es
eben so dass in dem moment wo die
periode 1 setzt eben mädchen dann auch
aus der schule entfernt werden für die
zeit der periode um eben nicht
ausgesetzt zu sein eben den ganzen
durchfeuchtungen von von tüchern das
sind oft einfach stofftücher die
verbände der länder oder weiß ich was
genau und das heißt diese mittel stehen
nicht zur verfügung und deshalb werden
dann die mädchen eben zu hause behalten
dann verlieren sie den anschluss dann
wird das natürlich offensichtlich sie
sind jetzt fruchtbar
das heißt da kommen diese ganzen
dimensionen auch wieder rein der der
umgang mit mit männern dieses dieser
fokus der dann da ist die angst der
familie passiert da was das heißt kriegt
man quasi diese heirats anspruch nicht
hin
und von daher führt es dann eben dazu
dass es gibt so statistische erhebung
dass ungefähr 25 prozent tatsächlich von
von mädchen aus diesen gründen auch aus
der schule raus gehen und ist eine hohe
zahl wobei man sagen muss das sind jetzt
die statistiken linien sind ja auch
nicht so verlässlich und großer sektor
in indien ist eben auch privatschule
also die öffentliche schulsektor ist
nicht der dominante in indien also da
ist es noch mal anders auch
einzuschätzen aber ich glaube ein ganz
wichtiger punkt ist tatsächlich der
zugang zu diesen hygiene möglichkeiten
weil das einfach mehr freiheit gibt aber
ich kenne das aus meiner eigenen
erfahrung als ich in den achtziger
jahren in indien war also dass der diese
binden die waren so dermaßen teuer also
das war eine woche unterbringung in
einem gasthaus
um ein päckchen binden zu finanzieren
und das ist natürlich in indien auch so
dass das unglaublich teuer ist weil es
eben da kommen wir wieder auf den
kapitalismus weil es eben diese
produktion nicht als massenproduktion in
dieser weise angelaufen ist
die diese ganze sache verbilligt das ist
ja dann auch ganz konkret kosten die auf
die frauen zugenommen ich möchte gleich
nochmal mit der periode armut
weitermachen aber um das noch einmal
aufzugreifen werden zuvor auch
angesprochen ob dann zum beispiel sperma
flüssigkeit beim man auch als unrein
gelten
und da interessiert mich jetzt noch kurz
es gibt ja auch diese diese pubertäts
feste wo eben so was wie die
fruchtbarkeit gefeiert wird und dann ins
diesen umschlag den sie gerade gesagt
haben gibt es denn irgend etwas
vergleichbares für den mann weil wir
jetzt die ganze zeit nur aus der optik
auch von der frau sprechen also eine
ähnliche rituelle begleitung also der
von von samenerguss und sozusagen das
jetzt die sperma produktion auf vollen
touren geht also das ist mir nicht
bekannt dass auch im hinduismus nicht
das ist etwas was quasi nicht wirklich
begleitet wird rituell weil eigentlich
diese funktionsfähigkeit und diese
fruchtbarkeit des sams um das mal so zu
sagen wird erst dann eigentlich aktuell
wenn man heiratet und vorher ist das
eigentlich nicht relevant weil das ist
eigentlich das heißt der der samen des
mannes gehört in die ehe
das ist interessant das zeigt auch das
wird nicht sichtbar gemacht durch auch
restriktionen aber das andere schon
jetzt aber eben dass das stichwort
perioden armut es gibt eben nicht nur in
entwicklungsländern sondern auch zum
beispiel hierzulande und 2009 10 hat ja
auch schottland jetzt diese
hygieneprodukte gratis zugänglich
gemacht frau lechner würden sie denn
sagen das hilft wirklich auch gegen die
stigmatisierung jedenfalls also ich
glaube diese repräsentations politiken
können mal ein wichtiger erster schritt
sein dass man sagt ja vielleicht
brauchen wir menstruieren der disney
prinzessinnen vielleicht brauchen wir in
den wirt mächtigsten bildern einfach auf
sichtbarkeit von diesen themen damit an
struktureller wandel daraus erwachse
kann wie eben das beenden von perioden
armut durch gratis zur verfügung stellen
von menstruation produkten oder aber
auch der kampf gegen die luxussteuer auf
die menstruation produkte der ja in
europa in den letzten jahren wirkliche
fahrt aufgenommen hat und ich glaube es
ist extrem spannend wenn wir uns so
ansehen diesen umgekehrt heißt also was
jetzt auch von frau marina gehört haben
bei sperma ist es ja wenn man sich die
darstellung in der popkultur oder in
kultur industriellen kontext man sieht
jeder hetero porno endet beim
samenerguss und das ist so das
glorreiche ende von dieser von dieser
sequenz wird total gefeiert das ist so
dass das das ist sexualität gehört
sexualität dann auch da gibt es ja auch
schon vier gegenbewegung und so genau
genau und ich glaube dass da schon
einiges im umbruch ist und dass wir da
mit mit dieser sichtbarkeit auch gegen
diese scham die ja doppelt und dreifach
auftritt wenn wir über perioden armut
reden weil zum beispiel ein schwarzes
mädchen
das ohnehin schon genügend rassismus
abbekommen wird dann noch für ihre
periode beschämt wird und dann noch sich
diese produkte nicht leisten kann die
hat ja mit rassismus sexismus und
rassismus zu tun so zu sagen und je
schwerer diese scham auf individuen
wiegt desto unwahrscheinlicher dass sie
schaffen alles strukturelle problemlage
darauf hinzuweisen weil ja die man man
schämt sich ja man traut sich das ja
nicht ansprechen und deswegen müssen wir
wirklich also auf allen ebenen daran
arbeiten diese dieser schweren charme
mental abzuwerfen wirklich dann nehme
ich das schlusswort ganz herzlichen dank
frau lechner nach wien für dieses
gespräch und ihnen frau marina was
haltet ihr davon findet ihr über
menstruation muss man öffentlich
sprechen oder ist das einfach nur eklig
schreibt eure kommentare hier unten rein
[Musik]